all right so i don't know about you but
i feel like talking about pizza it's
pizza night over here i am smelling
pizza as it's in the oven it's on my
mind
and i know we're supposed to be talking
about heat and thermal equilibrium but i
think we can make this work
now if you're impatient like me you
probably put a slice of pizza on your
plate as soon as it comes out of the
oven and you've probably noticed that
the bottom of the plate warms up
so let's think about what's going on
here we have the temperature of the
pizza
tea pizza
which is warmer than the temperature of
our plate tea plate
so since the temperature of the pizza is
higher than that of the plate
the plate starts to warm up
the pizza's temperature on the other
hand will actually start to lower
and this will happen anytime the
temperature of object 1 isn't the same
as temperature of object 2.
we know temperature is how we express if
something is hot or cold what does hot
or cold mean
temperature is actually the measure of
the average kinetic energy of the
particles in an object so let's digest
that for a second and break it down so
temperature
temperature
is the average kinetic energy of
particles
and kinetic energy as we know is one
half mv squared
so when the pizza is warm its particles
are moving faster than if it was cold
and when particles and objects are
moving they're actually vibrating around
so what's happening in the hotter object
is that the particles are vibrating
faster than when the object is colder
and that's what it means to be hot or
cold
this type of kinetic energy the motion
of particles is also known as
thermal energy
now you might be wondering if
temperature is the measure of kinetic
energy in objects and we have the pizza
and the plate with their temperatures
changing
does this mean there's some sort of
energy transfer going on here
and you would be spot on
heat is the transfer of energy between
objects at different temperatures
this is a really important concept so
let's write that definition out
heat
is the transfer
of
energy
between
objects
at
different
temperatures
as you can see with our pizza and plate
heat is transferring from the hot pizza
to the cold plate from the hot object to
the cold object
why is that
well let's go ahead and break down our
problem and really dig into what's
happening
with everything in the system
in real life a lot of energy is also
going to be transferred from the pizza
into the air around it
but for this problem we're going to
simplify it to just look at the pizza
and the plate
so we said that the higher the
temperature the more all the particles
that make up the object are moving and
vibrating so let's go ahead and draw
that for the pizza particles
we're going to use yellow to represent
the pizza
and i'm going to give the pizza
particles a longer velocity vector than
those of the plate and i'm going to
assume that the particles in the pizza
and the plate have the same mass that
way we can ignore the mass part of
kinetic energy and simplify the
situation now we can just focus on the
velocities of all the particles in the
system
when you put the slice of pizza on the
plate the particles at the surface of
the objects will come into contact
so let's look at what happens when these
faster particles from the pizza collide
with the slower particles on the surface
of the plate
when the particles collide kinetic
energy transfers between the particles
since the hotter object's particles in
this case the pizza have more energy
they're able to give some of that energy
to the colder objects particles
which is why heat always transfers from
the hotter object to the colder object
when the hotter object's particles
transfer some of their energy to the
colder objects particles the hotter
object particles have now lost some
energy and slowed down so we can show
that by using a smaller velocity vector
at the same time the colder objects
particles have gained energy and sped up
so now this particle in the pizza is at
a different velocity than its
neighboring particle in the pizza so
when they collide guess what we transfer
energy again the faster particle will
give some energy to the slower one and
in the process it slows down and this
domino effect carries through to all the
particles in the system in the plate and
in the pizza until all the particles
have the same kinetic energy
and when the particles in both objects
have the same kinetic energy energy will
no longer transfer between the two
objects and the system has reached a
state of stability and we call this
thermal equilibrium you know when you
leave your pizza on the counter too long
you come back and it's cold if you were
to actually measure the temperature of
the pizza in the plate they're going to
be the same and we now know that heat
transfer
only occurs when the temperature is
different between objects so when the
temperature is the same
no heat is transferring and this is what
is defined as thermal equilibrium
so thermal equilibrium equilibrium
occurs when there is no heat transfer
in the system
so it turns out pizza is actually pretty
good for learning about heat transfer
and thermal equilibrium and if you don't
mind that pizza in the other room is
calling my name and personally i prefer
to eat it before it reaches thermal
equilibrium with my plate